Elden Ring's DLC shadow of the UR tree
is rumored to come out next February
it's also rumored to have a showing or
release date announcement at the game
awards in December considering it has
been quite a long time since the game's
initial release and we're all basically
huffing a mix of copium and hopium I'm
going to assume these time frames are
reasonable this is the longest we've
ever waited for a DLC after the release
of a from software game so I'm willing
to put a bit of stock in it coming out
sometime soonish but that still leaves
the question how long or significant or
big will the DLC be Elden ring was from
software's biggest game to date and this
seems to be the longest they've ever
worked on a DLC so it should be kind of
big but that's not saying much so let's
see if we can find out a more specific
answer or guess looking at from
software's past games and their DLC
lengths and their release dates we can
try to calculate how development time
translates into DLC size this is
assuming DLC development starts around
the time of the release of the base game
and obviously this is going to be shaky
but it's something to do with our time
if we get a consistent past rate of Dev
time to DLC length we can use that and
the dev time that is gone into Shadows
of the earth tree to calculate how long
the DLC could be now the best place to
look is going to be at recent fromsoft
games of a similar kind to Elden ring
which probably means not der derine der
if we also avoid armored Core 6 as that
that is a bit of a different game and it
obviously has no DLC out yet we come out
with SEO Dark Souls II and bloodborne
SEO didn't have a proper DLC only a
notable update that added a few features
into the game so I don't think it's too
useful to look at here if we look at
Dark Souls I we have a game that got two
paid substantive DLCs ashes of Arendelle
and the ring City if we use data from
how long to beat we can see that in
total these DLCs came out to be about 13
hours of of content for an average run
if you explore everything it's going to
take longer and if you try to bum rush
it it's going to be quicker but 13 hours
as an average the ring City released
second and came out about a year after
the base game's release so this gives us
a rate of 13 hours of content for a year
of development for Dark Souls I and if
we compare that to the base game length
of doing just the main content at 32
hours we get a rate of about 40% of Base
game playtime per year of DLC
development I think having both of these
numbers can help us build a range since
obviously Elden ring is a bit different
from Dark Souls I being bigger and open
world the dev hours might not translate
one to one so having a number and a
percent can help get a spread of the
full possibilities next up is bloodborne
which features one of from software's
most acclaimed DLCs the old Hunters what
started as multiple DLCs ended up being
grouped into one package that released
about 8 months after the base game with
the the old Hunters taking about 8 hours
to beat that gives us 1 hour per month
or 12 hours per year of Dev time
compared to the average base completion
time for bloodborne we get a rate of 36%
of the base game per year of DLC
development so dark souls 3 gives us 13
hours or 40% per year and bloodborne
gives us 12 hours or 36% per year these
are very comparable rates so that could
be a sign that we're on to something
unfortunately the numbers get a bit
skewed if we look at Dark Souls 2 or 1
but to be fair Dark Souls 2i development
Journey was pretty wacky and if we start
looking at Dark Souls 1 we are going
back more than a decade in that much
time it makes sense for development in
from software to change and itself
develop a bit with that in mind I think
looking at Elden ring with our Dark
Souls 3/ bloodborne rate is a good idea
it's the best one we got at least so
Elden ring came out in February of 2022
if the rumors are true the DLC could
come out in Fe February of 2024 and if
the rumors aren't true it's probably
going to be even longer than that that
would give us at least 2 years of
development time and we do have some
reason to believe in the case of Elden
ring that DLC development was happening
almost immediately after release of the
base game so let's keep going with this
and see where we land with 2 years of
development and our rate of about 12 to
13 hours of content per year we would
get an estimated length of time to beat
the DLC at between 24 and 26 hours
according to how long to beat that is a
little less than half the time to beat
the main story of Elden ring which they
list as 58 hours in my opinion most
casual players that end up beating the
game put a bit more time into it than
that so maybe closer to 70 hours than 60
and that would put this DLC closer to
1/3 than 1/ half of the base game
however if we go by the percentage rate
we get an even bigger DLC the rate for
bloodborne in Dark Souls I can be
averaged at about 38% of the base game
length per year of development if we do
the calculation for 2 years 76% of the
Elden ring base game would give a length
of 45 to 50 hours so our current range
for the DLC would be 25 hours at the low
end and 45 to 50 hours at the high end
we could kind of argue either way in
terms of what is more reasonable Elden
ring is from soft's biggest game with a
completionist run going above 130 hours
plus we know there was a lot of cut
content that means a lot of potential
stuff for DLC all of this could point to
a really substantial DLC when we also
consider that this is the longest
they've ever worked on an expansion but
at the same time a 50-hour DLC would be
basically five times the length of a lot
of their previous DLC packages it would
be near 10 times longer than ashes of
Arendelle and maybe that's too ludicrous
I say maybe but that's almost certainly
too long besides with the base game
being a large open world the DLC could
be a chance for a more enclosed
traditional fromsoft experience which
would likely mean a shorter play play
time and even the lower end of our
calculation is still really long for a
DLC at 25 hours there's too much up in
the air to be certain we still don't
even know if the DLC will actually
release in February but we have a
somewhat reasonable range to choose from
after these calculations if I were to
let my gut Hazard a guess I would think
that the large size of the base game and
the long development time make a Long
play time for the DLC almost certain but
long in this case is relative a 50 hour
DLC just seems too far-fetched to me
since even a 25-hour piece of content is
longer than plenty of other AAA games
it's longer than one and maybe even two
runs of armor core 6 too so I would say
the actual number might be a bit longer
than our range minimum but probably not
too much I'd put it around 30 hours as a
maybe even optimistically long guess and
maybe there's a bit of Hope sprinkled
into that number two but we were all
shocked by how big the base game of
Elden ring was and I am am betting that
the design philosophy of Elden ring with
its length and open worldness will still
be present in the DLC to some or a
decent degree and any way you look at it
a 30-hour DLC is still a behemoth having
that be the lower-end estimate might be
a reach I think it is the more I talk
about it but with my seemingly
reasonable analysis bringing us to it I
don't think it's just cope I honestly
think we have reason to expect something
like that number for the final result
it's a huge game and it's a huge amount
of time they've been working on DLC and
obviously length doesn't determine
quality I actually think Elden ring
would be a better game if it was shorter
so maybe this DLC will be an opportunity
for that an Elden ring experience that's
a bit more focused which would probably
be my dream scenario but depending on
how far from leans into that we could
get a shorter than expected play time
which again I would be chilling with it
might be something I should be hoping
for considering I wanted the base game
to be shorter feel free to let me know
in the comments what you think about the
DLC and my calculations do you think it
will come out in February and be around
30 hours of content do you have any
reason to disagree in any case we'll see
if we get any more news or rumors before
the game awards and if not we'll almost
certainly get some news of some kind for
from software at that event until then
maybe I'll do some more elen ring lore
or videos on other games we'll see
thanks for watching peace